yann moix je sais que vous vous êtes
bien sûr pour l'accueil des migrants ou
sais que vous avez beaucoup irrité vous
avez beaucoup travaillé là-dessus où
vous avez même été sur le terrain on
connaît vos succès nous voilà vous vous
pensez qu'il faut accueillir ces
migrants
j'ai vu en faites des enfants pas y
aller j'appelle enfants des gens de 16 à
20 ans il y en a des beaucoup plus
jeunes y avait des femmes avec leur bébé
et c'est vrai que lorsqu'on rencontre
des individus et non pas des chiffres
étant donné que gilles a eu la
gentillesse de dire tout alors que
j'étais quelqu'un de sensible
on ne peut pas rester insensible des
gens de 16 ans qui vous expliquent
qu'ils ont traversé traverser le désert
libyque qu'ensuite on les a frappés dans
des prisons torturé en fait style pour
que les parents restés en erythrée en
afghanistan voilée civis qu'on fait sur
les enfants afin d'obtenir des rançons
que ces mêmes enfants traversent ensuite
la méditerranée pardon on leur fait
croire qu'il traverse alterné des
pirates arrivent les reprennent les
remettent dans la prison ils se font
ressortir et en redemande une rançon
donc en fait j'ai rencontré des
individus des individus qui m'ont
raconté leur histoire
or les histoires individuelles moi ça me
bouleverse les chiffres restent des
entités malgré le fait que j'ai fait un
peu de mathématiques qui me sont
totalement abstraite mais lorsque vous
rencontrer ces gens vous rencontrez des
aventures et c'est bouleversant et je
crois que dans une partie de la classe
politique aujourd'hui il y à une
confusion entre le problème de
l'immigration et le problème de savoir
suis dans une population de 760 millions
d'habitants en europe on peut accueillir
une dizaine de milliers de mères et
d'enfants qui meurent en méditerranée
presque tous les jours de manière
absolument inique et on a une
responsabilité par rapport à l'histoire
je veux pas faire de bons sentiments je
termine parce qu'on a discuté lors en
coulisses pour dire que je suis pas un
ange et liger juge pas dans l'angélisme
gros migrants il y as chez les migrants
j'ai passé aussi des mauvais moments
avec certains afghans
ce sont des êtres humains chez l'être
humain il y a le meilleur et le pire et
parfois chez le même mais la même
personne il ya le meilleur et le pire
c'est tout ce que je voulais dire alice
cordes et vous qu'est ce que vous
répondez ya deux mois alors déjà par
rapport aux faits qui se paie ce jeu
hadj est donc en espagne c'est
particulier parce qu'en fait c'est aussi
un choix politique les migrants
aujourd'hui sont manipulés ça a été on
sait que le maroc les a envoyés alors
normalement on nous dit
immigration c'est une cause humaniste je
vois pas en quoi c'est très humaniste
finalement d'aller envoyé des migrants
dans de petits villages espagnols qui ne
pourront pas les acteurs d'un coup parce
qu'on parle quand même de 2700 individus
comme d'en parler avec yann moix et ça
reste quand même d'utiliser ces
personnes là on peut se demander où est
l'humanisme la première chose la
deuxième chose vous parlez yann moix à
juste titre que ce sont des individus
c'est vrai c'est des individus mais qui
appartiennent à une culture particulière
aussi et on a remarqué dans un certain
nombre de chiffres
je veux pas tous leur sortir parce qu'il
y en a beaucoup trop que cette culture
là est une culture violente aussi
notamment à l'égard des femmes
il est bon aussi de penser à eux mais il
est avant tout bon de penser à protéger
les nôtres et moi c'est ce que je fais
tous les jours dans mon association
féministe en accueille des femmes qui
ont été victimes aussi de ces migrants
là qui n'ont pas du tout le même regard
sur la femme que nous avons en occident
et c'est à ce niveau là que ça devient
compliqué parce que il y a le réfugié
politique évidemment et le droit d'asile
en france est un droit sacré que l'on
veut tous maintenir mais le nombre de
migrants qui viennent aujourd'hui qu'ils
ne sont pas des êtres l'asile politique
mais qui sont bien des migrants
économiques
il y en a énormément et l'approché n'est
pas du tout la même et on le voit bien
notamment dans l'impact sur les femmes
il ya une volonté aussi de non
assimilation à une politique qui du coup
est très fragile à ce niveau là puisque
en accueille pas ouvrir une petite
parenthèse je dirais que moi les
migrants économiques ne m'intéresse pas
mais non mais limitée rang que j'ai
rencontrés ne sont pas des migrants
économiques que ce sont des gens dont le
prof de mathématiques était décapité
sont des gens dans les mains de la mer
ont été tranchées à faire au cas par son
nom mais moi je fais au cas par cas
c'est à dire que les erythréens que j'ai
rencontré les avant que j'ai rencontrés
sont des gens qui auraient adoré rester
chez eux ce sont d eric zemmour chez eux
sur des gens qui n'aiment pas les
voyages qui n'aiment pas l'étranger qui
n'aiment pas déménager les rencontrer
que des gens qui sont partis parce que
c'est une question de vie ou de mort et
quand je leur demandais quel était le
plus grand rêve de leur vie
c'était pas de se geler dans les quêtes
dans les taillis de calais en attendant
date dans un pays qui leur dit rien qui
l'angleterre où il pleut tout le temps
mais de rester chez eux les
l'immigration est constituée de gens qui
ont envie de changer de vie pour des
raisons dans la majorité des cas
économique les migrants que j'ai
rencontrés sont des gens qui s'ils
restaient chez eux auraient été violées
décapitées brûlées vifs
non on va étudier politique va devoir
passer au deuxième sujet très vite
gilbert dassieu madame c'est terrible ce
que vous
et vous dites ils sont manipulés qui est
terrible c'est les femmes qui se fondent
dans mais messieurs d'accord mais
laissez moi jusque là mais on passe
beaucoup migrants mais il faut aussi
penser à l'envers sauf hammam et humana
au pcd des gens sensés alizé lim grande
france le des voleurs et des violeurs ou
tout bien oui c'est sûr est présenté
dans les cas d'agression je vous donne
un exemple moi je sais que j'ai chez moi
moi je suis pas vraiment dans
l'angélisme elle a raison de dire qu'il
ya des problèmes
j'ai pu le vérifier moi-même parce que
la semaine avant que j'aille à calais
une réalisatrice elle totalement pro
migrants s'est fait violer dans un
camion par des afghans sanomat ça ne m'a
pas empêchée d'aller les voir sans
penser que j'allais vers avoir à faire
des violeurs j'ai eu affaire à des êtres
humains parmi eux il y avait des ordures
et parmi eux il y avait des innocents et
même des inoffensif
on parle pas de gentils ou de méchants
on parle d'êtres humains indépendamment
de leurs tares de leurs de la période
alors comment vous faites pour faire du
cas par cas
le problème déjà ses comptes du temps on
les laisse dans la rue donc à un moment
donné comment vous faites pour
travailler dans sa vie vous savez quand
yann à 2000 qui arrive de temps en temps
c'est plus ma vraiment dire que ce soit
difficile de faire du cas par cas
c'est difficile de faire du cas par cas
quand on raisonne sur des stats et
qu'est ce que vous leur offrez qu'est ce
que vous leur offrez un relais d'accueil
commun on a on a vérifié en france que
tous les villages vides dans lesquels
des syriens des afghans des erythréens
sont installés sont des villages ou n'ya
dans l'immense majorité des cas aucun
problème est en fait le vice et lancera
tous d'accord parce qu'il ya un vrai
tabou en france on n'ose pas dire en
france qui est peut-être des problèmes
il faudrait voir lesquels attention hein
d'immigration on a l'impression étant
donné que c'est aujourd'hui l'enjeu
numéro 1 des prochaines élections
présidentielles il ya peut-être après la
prédication
on a le droit de poser la question
peut-être que c'est vrai qu'un an mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec les migrants qui
sont quand même un nombre
c'est comme si dans un match de foot
vous allez voir par exemple un match de
foot au stade de france
pendant le match il ya combien de
personnes dans les gradins au match en
main dès 1001 90000 c'est comme s'ils
avaient mis neuf migrants neuf migrants
qui arrivent et pendant le match il vous
gêne vraiment vous croyez pas vous voyez
ce que vous venez de nous raconter comme
une histoire qui est juste
ben oui c'est ça une réalisatrice qui se
fait violer dans un camp de migrants
nous ça ne vous choque pas et là où je
rejoins gerald ni la raison ni de la non
mais attendez mon cerveau n'a pas
j'aurais pu mon cerveau et l'appareil
n'a pas immédiatement transformé cette
information en afghan égale violeur mon
cerveau c'est métaboliser de la
meilleure suivante en disant je n'ai pas
à faire des enfants de choeur je n'ai
pas à faire des gentils j'ai à faire à
la fois des innocents 10 offensifs et à
des brutes et la victime vous en avait
parlé avec al abbar également que j'ai
parlé avec la victime mais qu'est ce
qu'elle a vécu la victime considère
qu'elle s'est fait violer par des
barbares
indépendamment de savoir si c'était des
migrants étant donné que les chances de
la mer ce les dons mais le ratio
s'obtient à claque dans la face à greek
française qu'on va n'avait pas établir
une corrélation entre le fait que des
gens soient des migrants et le fait que
ce soit des violeurs ne sont pas tous
les élus avec orion et bien voilà parce
que sont pas deux des voleurs je
considère mes données